foreign
divorce is where you will sleep either
in separate locations or at least in
separate beds the diluted version of the
Sleep divorce rather than sleeping in
separate rooms and separate beds is
called the Scandinavian method which you
think is sounds so much more salacious
than it actually is which is essentially
you've just got two separate beds that
you put side by side and that's the diet
version of a sleeve divorce but I do
think that sleep divorce idea is
important because it is a taboo and it
also can marketly improve things for
people
so when we've looked at survey data both
in the US and also in the UK with the
national that the Sleep counselor what
you find is that about one out of every
four couples who are surveyed will tell
you that they have had a sleep divorce
that they will sleep in separate beds
and we think that that may be in part an
underestimate because of the stigma
associated with it and if you survey
people anonymously you get to a number
of almost one out of every three people
will admit to waking up at least in
different locations
and there is pretty good evidence from
the science as to why that number may
make sense you know why 25 of all
couples suggest that
when we study couples who are sleeping
together objectively on almost every
measure that we can quantify about sleep
sleep is worse when you're sleeping as a
couple relative to when you're sleeping
separately
the twist in the tail there though is
that when you ask people about the
satisfaction of sleep there is
definitely some group of individuals
that say look I feel more satisfied with
my sleep when I'm sleeping with my
partner than when I'm sleeping
separately despite the fact that
objectively their sleep is worse so I'm
not suggesting it's a a
one-size-fits-all
but I think the taboo comes from the
idea that well if you're not sleeping
together then you're not
sleeping together
and the exactly intercourse thank you
very much yeah can you just get over
this way it's my desperately unfortunate
Hugh Grant genes that has me sort of
trying to navigate around the topic
rather than just like saying it straight
so thank you Tim yes if you're not
sleeping together then you're not having
sex you're not having intercourse yes
but
the oh come on Matthew hold it together
turns out that the opposite is true that
when you get a couple who are sleeping
well their sex life actually improves
and it's probably for three reasons that
we've uncovered the first is hormones
the second is
sensitivity and the third is libido and
I'll try to
Park my acute ground and get right into
it in terms of the hormones take off the
gloves Matt take off the gloves come on
it's time I'm wondering what you what
you mean by saying take off the glove in
terms of this conversation but let me
just skip it you see you open the door
Tim and I walked right through here we
go or put on the gloves yeah I think
probably best but we know each other
quite well now so maybe anyway in terms
of the hormones firstly we know that
testosterone gosh it takes a pretty
sharp nosedive in males and in females
when you're not sleeping well males who
if we put them on a diet of maybe four
or five hours of sleep they drop their
levels of testosterone
somewhere by about 10 years of Aging so
a lack of sleep will age a man by a
decade in terms of virility it's also
true of estrogen in women and so when
those two sex hormones are not in play
you get a reduction in the quality of
the sex life
the second component and this is data
that we've only really got in females
less so in males but the the sensitivity
of female genitalia increases when sleep
is in high volume versus when people are
not getting sufficient sleep and we
think that's due to the estrogen that
when estrogen is in normative amounts
because you're sleeping well there is
greater vaginal lubrication which
therefore leads to Greater sensitivity
and greater pleasure by way of sex
and then the final aspect is libido
we've also found that when a woman
obtains an extra one hour of sleep
there is a 14 increase in her
desirability to be intimate to have sex
with her partner
and I find that interesting because if
you put it in context the FDA approved
drugs for increased libido in in women
things like I think it's called violisi
is one of them I know that will increase
libido in women by about 24
but here is the simple addition of one
hour of extra sleep you can get more
than 50 percent of that benefit drug
free question for you Matt how are these
drug companies measuring increases in
libido is it a self-reported one to ten
scale or something like that which can
be very fungible
it's self-reported so many of those
scales are subjective you know it's very
much like pain that it's when it comes
to libido it's somewhat difficult to
quantify and of course it's not just
about innate biological libido the
conditions have to be right you have to
have the relationship with your partner
which actually also reminds me by the
way when couples are not sleeping well
this is a study from UC Berkeley not
from my lab but
what they found is that they have more
fights they don't resolve conflict
nearly as well between them when they're
having a fight and the reason is because
you lose empathy when you're not
sleeping well your ability to empathize
within other individuals and we now have
demonstrated why in terms of the brain
networks you decrease that capacity for
understanding the other and no wonder
you're fighting and you're fighting in a
pretty poor way so what's the Playbook
what's the best practices good question
I think
I'm not suggesting that asleep divorce
is for Everyone by any means whatsoever
there are some people for whom they
adore sleeping with their partner for
lots of reasons safety security intimacy
but I think if you are interested in it
take us graded approach and I would
suggest firstly just having an open
gentle conversation and don't be
defensive about it the second is
don't suggest that it's permanent offer
the idea that look could we do this you
know Darlene could we do this for the
next week or the next two weeks and I'm
not suggesting it's forever let's just
see and let's just try it on for size
then I think what people misunderstand
about
sleeping together in the same bed is
what they miss they don't really miss
the majority of time because for the
majority of time you're asleep and
you're unconscious what you really miss
are the bookends of sleep that sort of
getting into bed having a cuddle saying
a good night and in the morning waking
up and doing the same thing so if you
have a sleep divorce what you can also
do is build that in so you know whoever
goes to bed first the other person comes
in you have your time you cuddle do
whatever you need to do and then you
leave and then you repeat the same
process in the morning you don't have to
do that every day of course it's not
going to be practical but in that way
you sort of get the benefits of sleeping
together whilst still having a sleep
divorce if that makes some sense so I
would just say you know be be honest
with yourself
feel like sleep divorce needs a Rebrand
maybe Furniture polyamory since you'd be
on separate pieces of furniture sounds
really sort of risque taboo kind of sexy
I am so stealing that because yeah when
you bring that up you know at a dinner
conversation and you finally admit it to
your friends they all think oh no
they're on the Rocks you know but
Furniture polyamory all sorts of you
know swings from the ceiling and oh it
sounds very exciting very exciting yeah
candle works on the nipples let's go
they're killing it yeah yeah yeah
exactly